Sagat a city is a ghost town ash from
the volcano is everywhere even without a
major eruption residents have already
been hit hard the ash from the volcano
traveled with the wind and unfortunately
it blew in our direction
it didn't just affect us physically but
also our livelihood
our business had to close down it'll
take a while to clean up I feel bad for
the workers especially those who rely on
our business to support themselves some
are already attempting a clean up but
the Philippine authorities are clear
things could still get much worse the
condition of the taal volcano remains at
alert level four that means a hazardous
explosive eruption could take place in a
timeframe of hours to days saladna
Morris or RL this is what the
authorities are afraid of as well as the
potential danger from lava an explosive
eruption could cause part of the volcano
to collapse into the lake triggering a
tsunami with no certainty over when
disaster could strike residents and
their livelihoods are left in limbo
our correspondent ana santos is covering
this story for us g'day to you on can
you tell us where you are right now and
what's happening where you are I'm
currently in Batangas which is about 40
or 30 kilometers away from Sal Vulcano
but this is an area or province that has
been declared under a state of calamity
because this is where a lot of the
evacuees have been transferred to these
are the residents of areas within the
Alpha Chi Thai and the nearby towns so
we're actually going to the different
towns here to check on the people in the
evacuation centers it looks like they're
going to have to be in evacuation
centers for an indefinite period of time
to all continues to
you volcanic ash from its crater but
volcanologists are saying that instead
of looking up at the clouds we should
look at the ground there's reports of
growl and sweating or ground and
squirrels breaking which is an indicator
that there's hot mother's being
accumulated and this is again another
indicator of possible or very close to
rupture it's just that at this point the
government cannot first cannot say not
even the authorities and the experts can
see exactly when Tao volcano is going to
erupt right now it's still a pressure
cooker that that people are consciously
monitoring okay and you know under these
conditions with this great uncertainty
about when tall will or might explode
what are the people you're talking to
saying about how they're coping with
being driven from their homes by the
volcano and and having to wait out an
uncertain period of time of being in
effect volcanic refugees if you will
today what happened forced evacuations
done and on a more urgent level because
some of the evacuations were flat
funding went back to their homes to
check on their livestock and to check on
the condition of their homes because the
accumulation of volcanic ash fall can
cause rooftops and structures to fall so
that was that's an indication of how
restless and empty they're becoming
especially in light of the news that
they may be displaced for an injured to
indeterminate or indefinite point period
of time additionally I have to tell you
that the it would be very generous to
say that they had basic accommodations
it would be more truthful to say that
the accommodations were squalid these
were classrooms that were converted into
rooms you have about 20 people squished
in there they're sleeping on cardboard
and and mats and there's like four our
bathrooms being shared by two three
hundred people so this is not a
sustainable status or can accommodate
for them and they really hope that they
can at least go to a place or go home if
they
can't go home for home to a place that
would have more humane condition for a
relocation Santos and butter Tonga
thanks so much for bringing us
up-to-date on what's happening where you
are